so these so-called pro-life Spider-Man
Mason deschamp just completed his most
daring climb yet we're mesmerized by
these and they're legitimately dangerous
on Tuesday morning he free climbed in
other words without ropes the tallest
building in Arizona the 40-story Chase
Tower in downtown Phoenix The Climb
received much more media attention than
many of his other climbs he was arrested
after getting the top as he often is but
he's out of jail now and he joins us to
explain why he once again risked his
life Mason champ is the pro-life
Spider-Man great to see you Mason thank
you for coming on congratulations on
Surviving yet another
um it's incredible tell us why you did
this
yeah thanks for having me on Tucker I
climbed these buildings because I want
to show people how to have faith over
fear abortion is murder and that's the
truth yet so many people my age are
scared to speak the truth they're scared
to offend they're scared to lose friends
but we can't be scared uh abortion is
just like climbing a skyscraper it's a
matter of life or death and we don't
have time for fear that's why this time
around I'm raising money for a woman
named hope she's 22 weeks pregnant and
she is partially disabled and I want to
show her that she doesn't need to have
an abortion and she doesn't need to live
in fear
did you raise money by doing this
yeah I raise money every time especially
by coming on your show Tucker
well I mean it's just such an amazing
story because you know on the one hand
your athletic ability and your bravery
is just remarkable and the fact that
you're doing it in support of the single
most unfashionable position in the
United States of America
and you don't care is even more
inspiring I would say have you talked to
Hope
I have personally not talked to hope she
works with counselors but I I'm praying
every day for her that she can receive
the help and care and and I know that
like what I do is risky and I know what
I do is dangerous but it's something
that that needs to be done and and like
I say everybody not everybody not
everybody can climb a skyscraper but
everyone can speak out and everyone can
help save a baby at a time by going to
let them live.org and helping hope uh
you know receive the support and care
that she needs
yeah I mean raising money for a woman
who's pregnant and doesn't want to be
and you're trying to help her I can't
imagine anything more virtuous than that
you'll be attacked but not at my house
Mason great to see you thank you thank
you so much checker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight